if you and I both speak the same
language we can communicate if we don't
we can't write they accept consider this
documentary where they interviewed
someone in the sea islands off Georgia
he says ever since radio and TV came to
town our way of speaking just became
more and more American
now we sound like them they sound like
us just one problem this interview has
subtitles because America this Gullah
speaker understands you perfectly but
it's not so easy to go the other way see
sometimes when languages come together
they create this really odd situation
where it's easy enough for one person to
communicate one way but it's much harder
in Reverse
today I want to get animated about that
including one time I noticed it myself
and even better three countries full of
people where this kind of asymmetric
intelligibility is normal do I finally
get to use this one I've been sitting on
it for a year it felt like such a native
laying so I'm in the store standing in
line with a hand basket full of what my
friend Xavier calls my rabbit food I'm
agonizing over whether or not to put
back the nuts they were on the pricey
side for what you're paying me these
days enter a fashionable woman she
glides over to the fancy tea juice
potion section the one that's for the $8
+ crowd not the $5.99 oh isn't that a
little pricey for nuts crowd seconds
later I swear out of nowhere
one of the employees is right next to
her in boxing stuff
I hear the eagerness in his voice when
he asks but you need help finding
anything she turns and sounds come out
of her mouth but no words oh wait no is
she speaking Italian our selfless helper
doesn't flinch he switches from English
on the spot no momentum lost the to
exchange a bit of banter and he shows
her down an aisle and their voices fade
into the store there's something I
forgot to mention though and it's why
the moments stuck with me when the
employees switched he spoke Spanish
yes Bono is gonna say no career Enya
which I find quite lovely
two languages were crossing paths but in
a lopsided way he was clearly having an
easier time helping her than the other
way around why well we could come up
with reasons he's eager to help maybe
he's heard Italian before maybe he's
used to juggling languages in short
motive and opportunity but one more
factor can come into play in situations
like this the languages themselves to
see how let's visit a place where this
kind of communication happens every day
this frozen looking area at the top of
Europe is home to a bunch of languages
plus a ton of dialects but focus in on
the Scandinavian North Germanic
languages Swedish Norwegian Danish for
most of us understanding another
language takes study and time but
Scandinavians are lucky their languages
are close enough that they can go next
door and mostly communicate Semmy
communication style it's like a triangle
a beautiful triangle of Understanding
this is mutual intelligibility and it is
glorious
but the triangle isn't evenly balanced I
hear it's much harder to semi
communicate in Swedish and Danish than
it is in Swedish and Norwegian and it
gets even more unequal in each pair if
you're Danish Swedish is easier for you
than if you're a Swede hearing Danish so
unfair it's asymmetric intelligibility
wow that's a lot of syllables we could
try to boil this down to like I said
before a motive and opportunity but what
if it's not the people but the languages
themselves that are creating
Scandinavia's asymmetry how could we
tell well the languages are close enough
that their grammar and mostly vocabulary
don't change much from tongue to tongue
the big difference is in how they get
pronounced so here's how a Swede says
Copenhagen sharpen the hum and now
here's a Dane now smart people decided
to measure this difference with the
levenshtein distance I'm not your math
teacher or your math
but here's the function if you really
want to play with it in its recursive
glory I'll honestly be doing the same so
we can nerd together solidarity the
results estimate what it takes to
transform one word into another so how
far apart cognate should sound danish
cognates should be more distant from
swedish than the way Norwegians say them
swedish and danish should be extremes
and Norwegians should settle down right
in the middle one of those authors
teamed up for another study hoping to do
even better using entropy again not your
math teacher here that's my mom's job
and she rocks at it but basically model
the uncertainty Scandinavians feel when
their semi communicating and guessing it
sounds an example Danish grammatical
endings can only have one vowel in them
but they're Swedish cognates can have
three this creates uncertainty for
Swedes listening to Danish so using
conditional entropy just how uncertain
is Swedish given Danish how intelligible
is that intelligibility
well calculating with a bunch of
cognates it looks like Danish - Swedish
should be more complicated higher
conditional entropy than Swedish -
Danish Swedish and Norwegian are lower
but we expect more of a challenge going
from Norwegian to Swedish than the other
way Denmark should understand nor way
better than vice-versa really danger
than they get the Danes Danish does have
a reputation for being the tricky one we
could do a whole animated tangent and
danishes very evolved sounds but here
one more time now come home enough said
so now we have numbers guessing what
intelligibility should be what happens
if we invite real speakers in for a real
test asks Scandinavians who used one of
the languages at home to listen to a
reading in another language then quiz
them how well did they understand did
high entropy predict low intelligibility
let's see Danes have an easier time
understanding Swedes and vice-versa
check Norwegians and Swedes understand
each other better perfect except wait
why are nor
Weejun speakers having such an easy time
with Danish I'm reading that right yeah
Danish should be hard for Norwegians but
these results make it look like
Norwegians understand everything better
than everyone why well researchers
speculate I'll have to leave in a
mystery this time but the reasons
probably bring us back to motive and
opportunity these three factors make
intelligibility happen not just in
Scandinavia but around the world written
Estonian looks more like Finnish to
Finn's than written Finnish does to
Estonians Lao and Thai are close but you
Lao speakers out there have a leg up
possibly thanks to Thai soap operas and
magazines Jamaican Patois speakers
understand English but the reverse is
notoriously vexing and my amazing
patrons pointed out Quebec French for
Parisians Romanian for Italians and
Spanish for many kids in the US so the
next time you can't understand someone
who understands you it might be because
they're motivated maybe they want to
help a well-dressed Italian it could be
exposure they've met your words before
like Gullah but most intriguing of all
it may be because something about your
language tilts the odds in their favor
just because you don't understand
someone it's no guarantee they can't
understand you thanks to my patrons for
voting for this and for keeping the
channel's heart beating and tongue
talking oh let me know if you have any a
symmetric intelligibility stories of
your own I'm collecting any good ones
and stick around and subscribe for
language
[Music]
you